oh my god I am now I'm not going to talk
to the cameras here right I can look at
either one my name is Jen Kirkman I
should be on mic great my name I know
what I'm [ __ ] doing my name is Jen
Kirkman this is my podcast I seem fun
the diary of Jen Kirkman podcast this is
episode 154 I've been doing this a long
time but never in front of a camera it
won't always be in front of a camera but
this week we are streaming live from the
all things comedy studio now let me warn
you it's a podcast you're supposed to
listen to it I ain't much to look at I
mean I'm the most gorgeous woman who
ever lived but I'm not gonna be doing
anything that you need to be watching it
for unless you just enjoy what it looks
like and I don't blame you there's a lot
of fun things behind the scenes I have
my computer which is connected to the
Wi-Fi I've got my papers I make notes
before this I have my mug that says rich
[ __ ] this is justjust one of them you
can buy this mug if you want it rich
[ __ ] the joke is that the dollar sign
is not covering up the iron [ __ ] so you
have a swear word on your mug and you
can get this at my website Jen Kirkman
now calm click on merch anyway or s toy
merchandise es TOI merchandise calm at
the Jen Kirkman store and get yourself a
rich [ __ ] mug now okay so I'm just
gonna ignore the camera but I wanted to
give you a special message if you have
never heard of my podcast it is a weekly
diary entry where I tell you all about
my life we've gone deep I've cried on
episodes people have gotten to know me
and the people in my life the people my
life have been like I didn't realize
you've been talking about me for years
there's a lot of fun stuff going on
there's recurring characters it's just
me doing a half of a strange voice and I
think you would like it if you like
confessional things then you'll like my
podcast and you can find it on iTunes
Google Play what the [ __ ] is not
stitcher what's the other thing we do
that's fun SoundCloud and if you go to
Jen Kirkman home click on podcast you
can find more information there if you
want to go back and listen to all the
archives which I recommend you do anyway
so we have a lot to get to this week and
when i walked in i was just perusing the
internet this is breaking news this is
happening right now well it was updated
nine hours ago this is not this is on
AOL calm this is embedded on UK this is
not [ __ ] the only thing I have a
feeling that Russia WikiLeaks Julian
Assange are [ __ ] with us like I feel
like they planted this story and it's
not true because it's just so hard to
comprehend that there are aliens but
astronomers say they have detected
strange possible alien signals from 234
stars and so it's coming and is room we
remember Stephen Hawking was like don't
[ __ ] with the aliens when they come
they're not trying to come to be like
hey guys what's up there they want to
kill he even warned against aliens again
as recently as September just I'll read
that before I'll read what's happening
and then I'll tell you how we're all
gonna die so the alien life has been
hard to find so far but two scientists
EF Bora and eat raw ta say up there's a
video playing say that it could be a
possible cause behind some unusual
signals they observed in their recently
submitted study the astronomers from
Canada's Loveall University have
documented that sounds like a fake
that's probably a very accredited place
but Laval sounds like something you name
your kid after like a disco trip how
have documented I'm drinking hot water
[ __ ] that hurt have documented their
identification of two hundred and thirty
four stars out of two point five million
which seemed a pulse light at a
consistent rate the paper discounts
possible interference from the
instruments or data analysis and doubts
that the signals were created by
molecules rapid pulsations or Fourier
transform of spectral lines no one knows
what these other [ __ ] things are
anyway but it is whenever we hear
something there like like literally an
alien spacecraft will land there like no
that's um that's a volleyball
it just looks stiff
print out here and have you guys ever
been to Arkansas yeah that's what
volleyball look like here just the
neighbors kids were playing we're like
but a giant thing crash-landed and it's
smoking and it's made of metal
that's a no you didn't see anything
so it's weird that they're like yeah
well it's not our usual molecules rapid
pulsations it's aliens it's bizarre to
me that they're just admitting it which
makes me think that I think it's over I
mean I don't this makes me want to when
I read stuff like this I'm like I'm
gonna start smoking again I'm gonna get
super drunk tonight and I don't smoke
anymore and I can't drink really cuz my
voice and it just makes me want to go
like [ __ ] I'm gonna get huge but
that's the first thing I think of is
smoking eating and drinking and then
just not working and sitting around
because if we have a month left let's
say before we rocked by aliens why would
you go to work why would you go it's
fulfilling that's not that's if you like
have I don't know lung cancer and you're
still trying to have some semblance of a
life and it makes you stronger but this
is they're coming if they're coming then
there's no like I'll go to work so I can
feel like I'm making a difference in the
world there's not going to be here
so I recommend I just feel like everyone
should start eating and drinking anyway
the signals okay the team proposed the
idea that based on findings from
previous research there's the
possibility and I know they're only
saying a possibility but my mind is
locked on this as that means yes because
if you're a little kid and you're like
can I have candy and your mom's like
possibly you won't stop until you get it
and there's a possibility that the
signals are caused by light pulses
generated by extraterrestrial
intelligence to make us aware of their
existence
and I also don't know if it's like an
actual alien like hey I'm a little thing
with a weird body and I'm 18 and I want
to hang out or if it's like you know
when you blow on a dandelion and it
flies everywhere that whole thing of
like that's life like I don't want that
kind of life I don't want like
technically it's life but it's like
[ __ ] amoebas I want things with
brains
that no better and they're like oh we
used to be you on earth and then we had
to leave because this one year we
elected Donald Trump for president we're
in this alternate reality where this has
happened before and they're coming back
to warn us but their bodies have changed
cuz they have to live in them in this in
space not that we're not in space but
you know what I mean we're in like good
space we're in like like if space were a
city we are in like the earth is like
the strip mall like it's a super
convenient part of space as far as being
human goes you can get all your needs
met at a manicure and you can breathe
and you can get water anyway is such the
team proposed okay the study also notes
that this small group was overwhelmingly
in the f-22 k1 spectral range no I don't
know what the [ __ ] that means
as Universe Today points out that
significant because this is a small
range centered around the spectrum of
our own Sun and our own Sun is the only
one we know of that has an intelligent
species living near it I assume that's
us despite the indications there's
certainly quite a bit of skepticism
concerning the possibility of aliens
behind these signals and the team states
that this hypothesis needs to be
confirmed with further work there's
always skeptics and boring people
they're like ah technically I think
that's um you just need to get some lens
cleaner on your thing home but um so
Stephen Hawking has said this before but
he said it again in September of 2016
which was only last month the
theoretical physicist and cause I'm most
like cosmetologist he'll do your nails
cosmologists Stephen Hawking has once
again warned of the dangers I like that
he did this one says isn't a reprint
this is he was like hey guys just want
to get back in the news and remind you
of a thing I said last year which is
seriously you don't want aliens visiting
so has once again warned of the dangers
associated with extraterrestrial life
contacting earth in a half-hour program
on curiosity stream reports CN et I
don't know what that is
a country-music Network what
see any T OC net tech website I wonder
what the C stands for [ __ ]
cuz I'm for it either stands for [ __ ] or
[ __ ] the renowned scientist has
explained the reasoning behind his
cautious outlook and it has to do with
how things played out on earth in the
segment titled Stephen Hawking's
favorite places the scientist takes
viewers to Ghoulia's 8:30 to see a
potentially habitable god earth-like
extrasolar planet located 16 light-years
away in a CGI spaceship while passing
the super earth Hawking gives his take
on alien life if intelligent life has
evolved on Glee s 8-3 to see awful name
oh wow I'm looking at a picture of it it
legit looks like Earth except bit more
yellow where our oceans are we should be
able to hear it says Hawking of the
planet which is at least five times the
mass of Earth or they could kick our
[ __ ] ass one day we might receive a
signal from a planet like this so that's
happening month later but we should be
wary of answering back meeting an
advanced civilization could be like
Native Americans encountering Columbus
that didn't turn out so well I am ready
if I don't ever want to die but if
you're like you could just die at 19
like an old person and you know they
probably will find you by yourself and
you're you know fancy but nice nursing
home eating your tapioca and that's not
to say that's not a whoa what was me I
you know I planned to UM be in the
relationship I'm in until 90 but as I
was saying men die first and/or he could
get confused in his old age and wander
down the hall I think he's like a bird
or something so you know you can't even
if the person you're with is alive with
you at 90 you can't count on them being
there for you and I don't mean that
negatively like they're gonna start
gambling but I just mean who knows
what's going to go on in
their brains if they have one left so if
intelligent life has evolved on Glee s8
3 to see worse name we should be able to
hear it oh I already said that oh ok so
my point was unless I die when I'm 90 I
don't want to die now but if someone was
like okay but it's gonna be from aliens
I'd kind of take that if everyone was
going there's no choice or they could
never come and we live another 50 years
no no I think I'd stay or if they're
okay if they're like the aliens are
coming you're gonna die or some people
don't but it's just gonna be kind of
[ __ ] here for 50 more years I
probably that's the I would take die
with aliens did you find out what
cenotes stands for nobody cares about it
only me it's a CBS tech website mais ce
matin stand for consumer it's a lot of
reviews oh yeah I think I knew that
Hawking's pessimistic take on alien life
is nothing new he's really like ginning
up the fear is that a word
fear-mongering I imagine they exist in
massive ships having used up all the
resources from their home planet such
advanced aliens or perhaps become nomads
looking to conquer and colonize whatever
planets they can reach if so it makes
sense for them to exploit each new
planet for material to build more
spaceships so they could move on who
knows what the limits would be it's so
weird because when I think of aliens I
think of them in this far-off sense duh
but I think of spaceships I got the
spaceship seem plausible I bet that was
a spaceship that guy saw and not a
shooting stars the government would have
him believe but then when we really get
down to brass hooks and we think about
these things people aliens on other
planets I'm like no no one else does it
a walk and talk and think and build
things but us and I guess that's my
inherent narcissism but I want there to
be I mean of course I believe in other
life but just because I can't imagine
and I'm like no
no one else knows how to put on socks
his views come from looking at the
trajectory of intelligent life on earth
if a similar one takes place between
aliens and humans then mankind will be
the likely underdog we don't know much
about aliens but we know humans if you
look at history contact between humans
and less intelligent organisms have
often been disasters but how do we know
they're more intelligent than us I mean
do they have Cheesecake Factory
like what what do they have on their
planet what how do we just assume
everyone's smarter than us
this is [ __ ] America damn it the
whole globe is America
there's certainly smarter than some
people I know but I can't name names
because I'm on camera I also shouldn't
when I'm not on camera and in a
microphone because it's the same thing
so I don't know I guess I'll just I mean
I'm keeping my phone on in case
something happens we can all imagine if
it happened during the first I seem fun
live video broadcast I would go down in
history like whoever was like JFK just
died which I think was everybody that
was on the air so it's really not a
thing and it's not like oh I'm just like
one of the three channels back then so
no one will really care somebody else
something like younger person where the
podcast will say it and then they'll be
like oh my god that was amazing
and then I'll be like I said it too and
everyone be like boom so all right I'm
gonna complain about a few things talk
about Christmas talk about this woman
trying to motivate us in this exercise
class by talking about the weekend which
is my least [ __ ] favorite thing but I
feel like I should be very honest with
you guys it's weird to do this on the on
camera one but I had a bout of
depression last week and I I know that
we talked about that on this show and I
feel like I've had some people email me
but it's not that they think I'm lying
but they think that because
you know it doesn't come up that much
anymore which isn't true really it's
just a constant that I live with that
then it must be over with and it's and
it is I mean I'm not medicated and not
that that's the goal or should be your
goal I just didn't have this everyday
pit of despair but so depression as we
know it is the not sadness but the
absence of feeling and so I went into a
spiral this week and I don't even want
to be honest about it because I feel
like it brings down my this is this is
the eternal struggle of how honest I
should be on these things it feel like
it brings down the image of me the
what's the word like not my cachet but
my you know you get too honest with the
listeners and then they start to not
believe in you and they're like am i
backing a loser here and so I was
getting depressed about my possible
future which is to a lot of people great
you know I just take my second Netflix
special my specials on there are well
they'll be two on there which is a giant
honor and a few people have have had
that and but a lot of those people are
selling more tickets on the road than me
and that's what I was starting to freak
out about was thinking about what
happens when it comes out what if
everyone hates it what if this is my
biggest fear what if the smart people
don't think it's smart enough and the
dumb people just turn it off and then
everyone else is just like I used to
like her but she's talking about too
many women's issues this special has a
lot of lady issues in it but I don't
know how else to talk about it because
I'm a lady in the world and I've been
traveling alone a lot for the past two
years so I've had a lot of funny I think
they're funny experiences and then I
relate them back to you know women in
this world and so I feel like I like
listening to comics that aren't white
talk about their experience and I laugh
and I go ha ha ha and I send my slaves
home early for the day and I go go you
know it inspires me but but I feel like
there's an easier thing now there's
still racism obviously
but I'm just talking about comedy
Strictly comedy the racism and sexism
within audience - comedian I feel as the
white people have an easier time
laughing at a comic that's not white
especially if it's a man because they
think that comic is cool in this kind of
white person almost condescending way
like I want Chris Rock to like me and
but guys I don't think laugh as much
when a woman is making fun and and I'm
worried about that and so I'm worried
about it being panned and then not
watched and then no one comes and see me
or I'm worried about the other thing
which is it's great but for some reason
people don't buy tickets to my shows and
I'm still stuck playing the same venues
I have been which for some people would
be enough food being a triumph but I
think I guess I'm more ambitious than I
thought I was and so I just immediately
went into a depression where I was like
well it's not gonna happen because I'm
old lady Magoo and no one cares and
someone younger is gonna do it better
and then they're gonna get them over and
just spiraling and then because I'm in
you know I do self-help and I do therapy
so I was talking to my man friend about
it and I was just like I need to vent
and he was like okay but here you're
leaving your spiritual life out of it
you know we all don't know what's gonna
happen and I was like yes I do yes I do
nothing's gonna happen it's gonna go
back just go down the rabbit hole with
me and he was like well but you you have
such a you know you're such a different
place than you were two years ago in
your life like you're more peaceful
you've calmed down you do this you do
that you've resolved a lot of deep
issues and I'm like yeah it doesn't
matter look at this and I made a list of
awful people that have succeeded this
year in their television shows in their
stand up and I was like then and they
never said a [ __ ] prayer in their
life from this person and I don't want I
working so hard for what am i doing work
on myself for that doesn't matter you
can get ahead don't get we good look at
all the sick people that get ahead in
show business and so but then a lot of
nice people get ahead in show business
and then a lot of people get forgotten I
this is what I do not want to be I do
not want to be like
Netflix right now recommended if you
watch a movie about divorce or I don't
want kids are I'm a strong woman it'll
say recommend it after you watch the
movie Jen Kirkman stand up I don't want
it to be documentaries about fans that
never made it but all the band's you
know and love her like I loved that band
but they never made it and everyone died
they didn't even commit suicide they
just spontaneously combusted and it's
pit of despair and I don't want that to
be like we recommend Jen Kirkman like
that's how I feel I feel like there's
this cosmic thing that is like I'm just
never gonna get past a certain thing and
that is historical [ __ ] that is just
a tape I've been playing in my head
since I was a kid where it came from we
can analyze I I'm aware of where it came
from but we don't need to discuss and
it's just negative negative negative and
so all I can do is love what I do and
keep doing it because there's a gotten
far enough but I literally couldn't do
anything else I don't know how to be a
secretary anymore because there's all
these programs I don't know how to use
and now a month ago I was daydreaming
what if my man friend made millions
suddenly this year I would just live off
of him and I told him my plan I said I
think I'm ready to live off someone and
he was like okay and so if someone a
month ago I thought if anyone bought me
a ten million dollar apartment in New
York and I could just have my hobbies
and go to thrift stores and do
fashionista and read magazines and books
and have intellectual conversations over
coffee and then continue them into the
night over wine I'd be happy and part of
me thinks that because I don't know if I
get like joy from working I mean I guess
I do but sometimes you just don't feel
anything you just do what you do and you
do it and then so we were discussing
that the other night and I was like no I
don't want to I only want to do comedy
in some form TV shows or standup and if
it doesn't work out I guess I'll just I
guess I'll just have to jump out a
window and I went to this crazy place
that my only options later in life would
be to slowly kill myself by like taking
up smoking again or you know I don't
know what getting it I
was I could not see past it but it
wasn't like laying in bed war was me
depression it was I was suppose I was
being funny about it but I couldn't stop
going down the rabbit hole and I wanted
to keep going down it and I was like I
don't have any more bootstraps to pick
myself up by enough already I'm tired
I'm getting old I'm give up and so I
don't know what I thought was going to
happen but I sometimes get I realize I'm
in a transition here and and that's what
so I talked about it in therapy now
here's another weird thing I do
sometimes I go to therapy and I've had a
moment like that during the week where
everything's horrible and I can't think
straight and I feel like I just don't
want to do anything and I just want to I
don't know what I well the aliens to
come get me and then I'll go to therapy
and be like I don't know if I really
went on this week and then we'll just
talk about something weird and I
realized I should tell her that I came
up with a great plan for my future which
is to feel nothing and slowly kill
myself and she was like that's
depression and I was like I know but I
don't want to be someone that's on meds
and doing this and doing that and she
was like doesn't mean you have to go
back to all that it just means when
you're in a transition you don't process
it well because of your history of
depression you go into that you're not
Tom Cruise it's like gonna [ __ ] do
this
yeah get pumped I'm not a get pumped
person I get a little bit jittery after
coffee and I'm like woo and I'll like
you know do one thing and then be like
oh that was great and then that's it but
so I realized I'm in the transition I
have been on the road running running
from the law for two years and now I
have to realize you have to take stock
of your life every once in a while I do
not like Los Angeles I genuinely do not
like it and I hate when people say to me
you know that and then people start
making crazy noises they turn into birds
and but yes I ran screaming from New
York 15 years ago because I had never
lived on the west coast I was a child of
the East Coast from age 0 to 26 or 27
and I didn't like snow because I didn't
skee and i just didn't know what he was
supposed to do in it and I'd gone to
Florida once a year I'd been to like
warm weather probably like eight times
and seven times in my life like a
tropical location and I just thought I
want to live there and I got to LA and I
was damn right I was broke as [ __ ]
i mean- thirty thousand in the bank at
one point I had a creditor standing on
my front lawn I used to live in a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] a house that it
looked like the floors were made of
cardboard cockroaches Echo Park
literally a crack den across the street
and and you know who lived in back of me
the hilarious she lived in the guest
house to my shitty house we both were
renting my roommate has since passed on
but the woman that lived in back of us
was Martha Kelly the brilliant comedian
and actress on baskets with Zach
Galifianakis and so Martha would come
and be on my front lawn and go um Jen
the landlord came and was looking for
you and he said that um that we're
damaging the dryer we had this crazy
landlord he was like like a slumlord and
he lived in Malibu but he only more
stained sweatpants all the time and he
was obsessed with this washer dryer that
he bought and he put it in the basement
and most things in Los Angeles don't
have a basement so if there's ever a
flood which there was often things get
wet but that wasn't the issue with the
washer dryer he was obsessed with you
know your natural like scuff marks that
might happen which now I realized you
can find the magic eraser by the guy
with the bald head mr. Clean Magic
Eraser but he would be like look what
are you girls doing to this and I'm like
um I don't even know he was acting like
we were having like a kicking party but
he would drive from Malibu to Echo Park
which if you don't live here that's 20
miles and in traffic two hours and to
shame us about that and it was a really
negative nasty time in my life and I was
working I hadn't temp jobs and then I
was working at Lifetime television which
was actually
a fun job I worked four days a week and
I was the person that if you went to the
website and watched a little clip of the
Golden Girls I had picked the clip and I
had written Rose gets her first kiss at
age 60 or whatever and but at the time
it was kind of getting depressing
because life time was starting to get
into the original content space and they
were trying to get into comedy and they
and now they do have great shows on the
air but they were talking men about they
want to find funny women and funny women
and funny women and I was in the web
department so I never had to deal with
the TV people but then all of a sudden
there was this thing that happened where
we were watching video on TV and then TV
and the web department wanted to have
meetings together and I'd sit in on
these meetings and they'd be talking
about comedians that they went around
town seeing and I would be sitting there
like I'm a comedian and I had some stuff
at that point I was on like I'd been on
Craig Ferguson and premium blend this
thing on Comedy Central in this show
late Friday on NBC and I wasn't a total
loser I just hadn't like you know hit
any hump yet but I think I'd even done a
comedy album with a special thing
Records and I had a little fan base at
the UCB theater nowadays they don't know
me because it's been so long and I walk
in they go ma'am ma'am you need a ticket
ma'am I'm like excuse me look at the
wall that's my picture oh it's not what
my picture used to be there um so and
they and I was so depressed but I loved
Los Angeles so much that I would leave
the building and go look at those
mountains look at those palm trees look
at you can see the snow-capped mountains
in the distance I'm not at the beach but
I could I could go it's too far away and
annoying but I could go and and I felt
like I loved it and it was definitely
cheaper than New York in a lot of ways
and it was new I guess but now it's not
so new and everyone's older and it's not
a good city to be an older person in
because as you get older you get more
settled and you would like to stay home
and be with your things be it your
significant other or your dog or your
magazines or your Netflix or your
whatever or you what
no you work hard you work from home it's
not a let's go out place it's more like
let's catch up over drinks and then you
keep postponing it so when you live in
New York there's a youth that's thrown
at you that you don't even know you
still have in you where you can meet
someone at the last minute because it
doesn't take too long and you walk over
here and everybody's up and even when
you're sitting in your apartment you can
hear other people outside and and I
don't mean like whoo you hear people
going like I'm at [ __ ] kick your ass
Alicia I'm sad I don't want to hear that
but you're the city and beep beep and
beep beep and that that and um there's
something about that's invigorating so I
feel like I'm just in a different phase
in my life now we're needing to be
invigorated I don't need to live in a
two-by-four with a rat so I have to wait
until I'm making Bank to move there and
thus brings me to my problem I've got to
make Bank now I don't know maybe could
someone could hack my phone or some I
mean I don't really have anything
scandalous um but you know now that
that's although I did get a call once
from Apple and they're like someone's
trying to get into your account you have
to do this protective thing with your
iCloud and I was like that's horrifying
because you don't think there's anything
in your phone you're not having an
affair there's no scandal in your life
you're not like leaving your company to
start a new one and be a competitor you
know you're not secretly a pedophile or
something you know but if you just quick
look at your text you realize no scandal
but man do I not want this out there
like this text my friend sent me please
look at the photos that posted from Boop
he looks and then I'm like oh my god he
does hang on
I just don't get him but I also don't
take him that seriously oh also here's
an article to that person we hate OOP
continued [ __ ] you to them finally
people are picking up on that they're an
[ __ ]
oh my god thank God that Boop is so
[ __ ] full of boob self I can just
tell by that pic we would be screwed if
these texts got out they are about
people in the public eye people we know
Friends of Arts so I really don't want
my phone hacked is my point even though
I'm not doing anything wrong I'm not
doing anything right so I was depressed
and just talking about it actually
helped and I think that is what happens
when you live with depression for so
long sometimes you kind of just get so
used to it when it flares up that you
don't talk about it and then when you do
you go okay I just didn't want someone
telling me it's going to be okay so you
don't know that and it's true they don't
they're just trying to cheer you up
but you don't know either way you can
just you just have to keep doing what
you're doing but you don't have to feel
enthused about it a great tip is act as
if act as if everything's gonna be okay
you don't have to believe it and then
eventually you find yourself believing
it but I guess so that's what came out
of that depression and um and now I'm
like what was I talking about
if someone bankrolled me and I could
just move to Paris and read I don't I'd
be so [ __ ] happy but the other night I
was like nothing nothing will ever make
me want to live life it is just I failed
at everything and so luckily that has
passed but you know I had to work it out
and I realized something about myself
that isn't applicable to this
conversation but oh I forget what I was
saying but anyway yes I used to love LA
now I don't
I think people change I know I think
allow you're 42 year old friend to be
different than she wasn't she was 26
don't be like that you used to love it
look at you coming back it's like what
not really I think it's a classic New
York LA thing - you love one you get
sick of it you go to the other and then
get sick of it again and go back so
anyway so this is what I did this week
possibly to combat the depression but
also because I would have anyway I
ordered I went on Pier one calm
not a commercial but if they want to pay
me that's fine first of all I ordered
online because I didn't want to go into
this store because it happens every
[ __ ] time do you want to open a
credit card and save 10% nope I knew
what the price is where I knew that you
would offer 10% off whatever the
difference is I have the money I'm
buying it like imagine if you wanted the
10% off but you didn't qualify for the
credit card and you're like [ __ ] I was
banking on that 10% off and then you had
to return things oh that was my point so
years ago when I lived here
what and I still live here when I'm
living in Echo Park I have this credit
card debt I really didn't know you had
to pay credit cards I was so stupid
I had like a generic credit card you
know five hundred dollars and you keep
building your credit when I was in
college and I just maxed it out and then
some and I think that then you couldn't
withdraw the money and I've been eating
up and then I was just like well I'm
gonna move so I don't have to pay it
thought I could fool him but change a
mess up code and I moved to New York and
then that followed me and I had a bed
bath no I had a bath and Bodyworks
credit card a Victoria's Secret credit
card and expressed the limited Express
credit card I think I had old Navy or
the gap and everything I think I hear
what how to Pier one credit card and
IMAX them all out and just didn't pay
them and my credit was bad for eight
years I think it like even with you know
making good money and having people help
me handle it I still couldn't get I saw
had bad credit for a long time that [ __ ]
won't leave you so don't [ __ ] around
kids because we were an adult you
actually need credit cards to run your
business or travel and it's nice to get
points and all that kind of stuff so I
[ __ ] up but there was a creditor or
someone standing on my front lawn
yelling my name and look like a movie
where a guy was in love with me except
he wasn't he was paid to give me a
warrant for my arrest and I stood on my
front lawn in Echo Park and I was like
oh my god and now that I look back on it
I don't know if it was a warrant for my
arrest it was a
not a warrant for my arrest the thing
you give when you're getting a divorce
you hand someone papers like I'm suing
you is what it was it was I'm suing you
subpoena a warrant for my arrest here
you go do it you will win that a
subpoena I got subpoenaed by somebody
out of one of the creditors and I was
losing it literally losing my [ __ ] I
think I probably ran in the house and
had diarrhea and I like can't even
remember how I dealt with it I just took
it step by step and I got on a payment
plan I mean it was a small one like
fifty bucks a month for 30 grand of debt
and it took me so long to pay off and
every year that I need more money I made
those payments bigger and so I don't do
credit cards anymore except for my one
main credit card that I use for travel
or you know if I'm buying a bunch of
things like Christmas gifts on or
something but I don't have credit cards
for individual stores not because I
think I'm gonna go crazy and spend all
this money I just feel like it's easier
and I like getting all my points on one
card for my travels in mine whatever and
that sound think it's anyone's business
so I go to here when I go to Pier one
it's like do you want to start a card no
I only come here once a year but you
save 10% I understand but I don't want
to fill out the form I want to use my
credit card I want to get my points I
want to manage it the way I manage it I
know but how can you give up 10% it's
easy you gave me the price I picked up
the item that's what I plan to pay for
it this 10% is a whole new thing I'm
fine
so it never ends it's it's literally to
the point where I'm crying and I'm like
so I'm triggered you know and then
they're running after me and they're
like ma'am ma'am wait and I'm like I
don't even want the lime cozy but has
fur on it I don't want the fake fur
thing you put around the wine bottle I
don't want it just stop pressuring me
so I decided to do my shopping on Pier 1
calm and they're having a sale and that
way I could just go pick it up and no
one would be like do you understand
because I would have already paid for it
and it's a brilliant way if you don't
want to spend too much money to shop buy
it online you go in the store you're
tempted you're like overwhelmed and you
might
pick out what you want so I've been
working on my Christmas decoration list
for two months and I've decided where
what goes where and what I'm gonna buy
and I put everything in a shopping cart
on Parowan comm and I bought it and I
went in and I was the Christmas
decorations are already up which makes
me so happy
like the Halloween ones are shoved in
the corner like [ __ ] you you wish you
didn't get bought this year and there's
still 10 more days for that witch to be
purchased but they have to zero faith in
her she's in the corner and now they
just have oh end they have the most
eclectic Christmas decorations like
feathers and this and I just get
overwhelmed and I walk in am I good and
I didn't buy anything extra but I'm
pretty excited about my purchases I have
a pillow that's white velvet with a big
snowflake on it and it lights up and it
can light up solid or blink and if you
want to have a seizure at my house to
come over I'll put it on blink for you
so I was pretty excited and I got home
and I unwrapped all of it and it's
sitting on the couch in my home office
and it's just like we're ready we're
ready and on October 1st I am going to
put up my decorations out my tree just
my decorations and I can't [ __ ] wait
and my handyman who's lovely I think I
talked about him months ago because he
got all these good and Yelp reviews to
the point where it was creeping me out
like he saved my baby's life he
performed an emergency tracheotomy but
um he isn't like Hillary which is fine
here I have to like her but he's like a
burning dude conspiracy a little bit
Hillary's corporate every issues same as
Trump and he's like my mom is just like
you she thinks she's gonna be great
so I was I had to make a decision do I
want this guy coming over before the
election or after because I know after
he'll be fine him be like great Trump
isn't president but before I don't be
like I don't know I'm looking at those
emails you know he's someone that's like
reading the emails so much but you know
what I want that now you're like why do
you need a handyman it because I've got
intricate things this year I've got
giant rows of garland Preem lit LED
that's going over like
my sliding doors and I want he's really
good at like hiding the work like how
you nail things in and I can't do any
that [ __ ] so I might have to do it a
little bit of like you know conspiracy
but I already voted a voted by mail so I
might just tell him it's lost on me I
could just say I actually don't agree
with anything you say it's hard when
someone's in person and they've got a
hammer so I think I'll just leave that
but I was so excited to get those up so
that's gonna be November first nobody
bother me between 10:00 and 11:00 a.m.
and then I'm putting the tree up on
November 8th the night of the election
everyone else will be an election
parties I'll be home watching the
results come in and putting up my tree
because two things I have been so
[ __ ] anxious about this election that
I just need something pretty to look at
number two lightness and the time of
dark we talk about it every year it's
gonna be dark if Trump wins I don't
think he's going to but anything can
happen
we got aliens contacting us do not tell
me that you know the future if Hillary
wins it's gonna be dark because people
are all mad because they've been told
the system is rigged and I'm afraid of
riots not like outside my door but I'm
just afraid of four years of people
hating women so if if it makes me feel
better
Jen what did you do the four years that
everyone hated women I put a Christmas
tree up and that's what I want to do I
might wait but the Grove in LA is
putting their tree up November 13th oh
my god and if you can believe it I
already know my Christmas card is gonna
be this year and I can't it's so
exciting I'm sure someone's done this
but I have an amazing photo of me I
think it's amazing when I'm 5 years old
and I'm sitting on Santa's lap he was in
our kitchen my dad's friend Jack kid
dressed up as Santa Claus and I knew it
was Jack and Jack was a little bit of a
drinker and I knew Santa smelled like
booze and I've got my nose right to his
and you can tell by the intensity of my
pose that I'm like you're not Santa and
I love that picture so I want to go to
the Grove which if you guys again don't
know what that is because you're not in
Los Angeles and
our giant mall that's outdoors but they
have a hundred-foot Christmas tree every
year and then Santa's workshop and even
a trolley that takes you from the gap to
top man what more could you want you
think the aliens have that on their
[ __ ] cleanest planet you think
they've got a trolley that takes them
from gap to Topshop and you can hop off
you can hop off and go to Cheesecake
Factory you can hop off and go to the
Apple store there's no [ __ ] way these
[ __ ] have that they might be smarter
than us but they're not more fun there's
no [ __ ] way the aliens are more fun
than us so I'm gonna sit on Santa's lap
as a grown woman I'm gonna try to I
can't recreate the outfit totally
because I was wearing a red turtleneck
with blue pants with flowers on them and
I don't own something such as that
anymore but it would be close and I'm
gonna put a little red little girls
Brett in my hair is this creepy actually
now that I'm thinking about it out loud
and I'm going to sit on Santa's lap and
recreate the pose and then we're gonna
put the two pictures side by side and
we're gonna send it off and that's gonna
be my Christmas card but I don't want to
look like I'm not gonna be like a porn
star like short skirt hey Santa tits out
it's literally just me recreating the
photo as an adult because I try to do
fun in different things
because the people I send my cards to
are all the people that I hate this do
not send pictures of just your [ __ ]
children that you're not in I don't know
who you are I don't know who sent this
it looks like I'm a pedophile there's
just pictures of children all over my
house and it's never Christmas themed
it's just like a picture from your trip
this summer I don't care
we know what I want a picture of your
grown child and I'll go oh great you
know what that means
I can go back over their house now and I
don't have to talk baby talk it's been
20 years since I've seen Julie thank you
for sending me a picture of your adult
son thus ensuring that when I come over
for a wine I don't have to pretend that
to be interested in putting your kid to
bed so I try to make it fun last year I
took a collage of different places I'd
been all over the world and in the
center of it was a big picture of me in
front of the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree giving a peace sign and I
said peace to every corner of the world
I thought it was very timely I'd already
had them made up and then the Paris
attacks happened and there was a lot of
Isis fear especially a lot of Isis fear
and my family family lives in
northern Massachusetts and southern New
Hampshire and I'm I'm not sure we've had
an Isis attack there but every one up
there's prepared they're thinking about
it always talking about Isis and so but
a lot of people my family and do not
like the card I think some people found
it not politically correct they felt
that they don't want to wish peace to
the world because there's some bad
people out there that we need to shoot
so I apologize I didn't write let's [ __ ]
up some Muslims on my Christmas card as
some on khals of mine would have liked
but so I try to do different things
because I'm not married and I don't have
kids and no one in my family ever goes
how are you do you have a relationship
that makes you happy you don't want kids
right I never bought your book sorry
like there's just this assumption that
I'm lonely and everything's terrible so
I try to make it fun like here's my fun
life I'm traveling I'm thinking I sat on
Santa's lap as a 42 year old that's fun
and then I have a little app that makes
two pictures go next to each other like
come on you guys I'm living it up I got
a full life here and so I think my life
is great but the people with the kids
and then they get my card and it's like
mmm there she is alone again but I don't
believe in putting boyfriends on
Christmas cards I think it's tacky and I
don't care for together 15 years it's
like we don't live in the same house I
guess if we lived in the same house it
would be from this household so yeah
like upon moving in together I think you
do joint Christmas cards but I don't
want to have to write on the back you
know I'm really into living alone for as
long as possible because I've already
been married and if we ever move in
together it's gonna be moving to New
York and again as I said if you listen
to my podcasts on this one episode it's
gonna have to be in a 10 million dollar
apartment that might take years so don't
worry about me I'm having a great time
just thought it would be funny to sit on
Santa's lap thanks but you can't say all
that in a Christmas card but I'm [ __ ]
so excited so Santa is coming November
13th to the ground modulus and he will
be there every day from 9 a.m. to 8 p.m.
seven days a week and I am gonna [ __ ]
get on his lap and I won't get there at
9:00 a.m. and what kind of weird parent
takes their kid at 9:00 a.m. instead of
school so hopefully it'll just be me and
hopefully I'll do it I don't want to get
some D
CAD Santa that's like Oh ho-ho and still
trying to pretend like dude I am onto
you I know you're not Santa but do this
picture so yeah Christmas decorations
ordered oh I didn't tell you guys well I
didn't even I was I'm supposed to tell
you but I'm gonna be in a movie
I had this uh it's it's three scenes
two of them are wordless it's just sort
of like the girls are all together and
then one scene is me I I don't know if
I'm actually don't know if I'm supposed
to say it so I won't say it yet but it's
a big star female star and it's a movie
she's in directed by a really amazing a
director who's quite known and
successful in and as I would say
historic and so I you know don't think
I'm shake this fear Shakespeare wasn't
an actor you know uh what name an actor
I'm not this amazing uh you know I I
actually can't act I went to school for
it but to me I can't call myself a good
actor unless I cry on cue and I'm like
you better give me my baby back and I'm
like southern and I'm like playing a
foster mom in a mine so um but it's a
very easy scene it's um of course I'm
overthinking it I'm doing the lines in
my head but it's we're congratulating
our friend on her new business venture
it's her birthday we're trying to set
her up with someone you know girls
having drinks but in this movie I have
to say a line about going to pick up my
kid which i think is funny and it was an
interesting story I had gotten off the
road I was home for one day after taping
my Netflix special and I thought I had a
fever because I was sweating a lot and I
I think I did and I was getting sick but
I never got sick and I went to without
showering and no makeup and my hair was
dirty like greasy dirty I went in my
sweatpants and drove into the city I
live in the valley I drove into West
Hollywood I went to this health store
place to get some healthy things and I
get a text from my agent
this director would like to see you
right now I was like I don't have any I
think I have a fever I'm sweating but I
knew usually in an audition they'll say
you're gonna go read on tape the tape
you and a casting directors there and
you can blow those off because the odds
of you well you shouldn't blow them off
but I do so when the director calls and
I went and we met and then I improvised
a little and I was like please tell her
I'm coming in sweat pants and I'm
sweating and I feel like that was like
kind of a good conversation starter and
so then I found out a little while later
that I got the part and I'm filming this
week so that would be super fun you will
see me it's very quick it's very quick
I'm not putting myself down I'm just
saying nobody get excited we're not
buying the New York City apartment from
that one but it's pretty cool I've never
been on a real movie set before which
makes me sound like a loser which what
you haven't been on one person watching
it so but you're like but you're in the
business that's true but I think it'll
be super exciting and I just hope I
don't completely overthink it and go
it's your birthday have a good one and
then just act like I've never said words
before which is a giant possibility but
I don't think so
so I'm doing that and once I can tell
you what it is I'll tell you I'm sure
it's fine now but what if it wasn't you
know like it then I get on set and
they're like so someone here has a
podcast and they were talking about this
is his top secret so I was gonna read it
email do we want to read an email on
camera I think I'm wait yeah I'm just
gonna talk about I took this power plate
class if you don't know what it is Clint
Eastwood loves power plate everybody and
Mark Robert big fans of it you're on a
plate it's shaking and zero graph I
don't know it's it's crazy it's a way
harder workout than if you were doing
these things not on the power plate and
I went on a Friday at 10:30 a.m.
so if
you have a job you've had jobs before
you're usually at work Friday at 10:30
a.m.
you are not at a power plant class so I
assume everyone in the class either some
people maybe had the day off or some
people were gonna go into the office
late that day or some people work
freelance or run their own business but
it didn't seem like anyone was your
basic nine-to-fiver
including the woman teaching the class
and so because I know that she was on
the schedule to teach all weekend and so
she kept being like come on guys you've
earned it it's the weekend and it's like
no one here has a normal life
there's no weekend to us I don't even
know what [ __ ] day it was and
Saturday I had to work I was writing on
something and then Sunday I had to do
some work so there wasn't the weekend I
was [ __ ] dreading the weekend
dreading it come on you've earned you've
earned where you're gonna go each night
I'm like eat tonight I have a fitting in
the morning I can't [ __ ] eat I get so
mad when why do people lazily say things
like that when they themselves don't
have what they're talking about no one
in that room was having a weekend
including that [ __ ] woman there was
no world where she wasn't gonna have to
be at work all weekend and it why
couldn't she just say you made it to
class today you obviously all don't have
real jobs or run your own business and
that's not very motivating so good for
getting your [ __ ] asses here and I'm
sure you'll eat and drink twice as much
as you've burned off tonight and you'll
probably blow it off tomorrow but anyway
you're here now and I don't need to
inspire you I just need to keep playing
this horrible air raid signal music and
the workout that I'm doing when I listen
to that [ __ ] is I'm just like I pretend
I'm actually running from a nuclear bomb
do you know what music I'm talking about
yeah I'm not gonna read letters that's
way too boring I'm going to end early
because I have a recorded I've a
recorded a second part which is you know
I read those articles so just the next
part if you love Trump and you're voting
don't even listen if you're on the fence
undecided third partying it I'm just
going to be do two more articles
everybody set your DVR
October 29th a wish for Christmas on the
Hallmark Channel the first of the
Hallmark Christmas movies begins and I
tell you this year I'm gonna write one
for next year I have a good idea I am
not telling you people because you will
steal it but it is called a match for
Christmas and the logo is someone's
striking a match and the flame is a
heart and you don't you dare steal that
you don't even know the plot but that's
what's gonna be I wish for Christmas
starring Lacey Chabert I don't know if
that's how you say her name her name is
in the movie Sarah Shaw is the type of
woman who prefers to sit on the
sidelines at work but when her big idea
for a Christmas initiative is stolen she
makes a wish to Santa that shall finally
have the courage to stand up for herself
when Santa grants her wish and gets a
chance she gets a chance to prove
herself to her boss she'll discover how
to speak out on her own this is a very
feminist movie just in time just in the
season of all this strife towards
towards women and I think we're ready
for a female president we're ready for a
Hallmark Christmas movie about speaking
up to your boss this is exciting stuff
and I watched a clip of it and my
favorite part and I god I love these
movies as she's talking to her boss and
her boss goes if you want that job in
Paris then you have to make the best
Christmas display in history in history
do you know how much pressure that's
gonna be on Sarah Shaw played by Lacey
Chabert to get that job in Paris what
job they don't specify that job don't
ask questions move to Paris find out
later what your job is
this is the Hallmark Channel we don't
have time for all this exposition we
could have set it in one line now [ __ ]
you more scenes of people in New York
City in the winter without hats on
scarves that just hang around your neck
and you don't tie him around it I can't
wait why would you wear gloves it's
negative - you don't need gloves what is
that that's a parking spot on the Upper
West Side
I'll pull right in god I can't wait I
can't [ __ ] wait for these movies and
their commitment to not being realistic
representations of any big city that
you've ever been in and I don't care I
don't want them to be accurate and so I
owe
also Saturday October 29th this is funny
if you guys want to come see me this is
not anything to do with all things
comedy but I won't be at the Pop II W
Pop fest in downtown LA and I got this
email from this publicist I sometimes
work with who I'm not currently working
with because I'm not promoting anything
but she got an email and she wrote to me
and said I'm working with the newly
launched two shorts boom box podcast
that's right too short
hosted by legendary rapper too short
himself he's been added to the e W pop
fest lineup and short asked me to see if
gen would be interested in joining him
in the boys on stage for a live
recording we're looking for a funny
female perspective on hot topics I don't
know this is what publicist say they
don't go we pitched you or some producer
that's booking it for too short who has
no idea what's going on ask for you
that's probably all it is is like
someone who's a fan of the Howard Stern
wrap-up show and they've heard me on
that and they're the producer but I love
they don't ever tell you that when a
publicist invites you to something it's
always like so short asked if you'd run
too short did not go
I'll get Jen Kirkman for this that's not
a thing that happened and if it did [ __ ]
all of you I'm cool so I will be on
stage with him I believe oh no I'm not
in his just go to e W pop fest calm
slash boombox
it's Saturday October 29th 2 to 3 p.m.
it's an estimated 15,000 guests will be
in attendance I think that's over the
whole weekend
I can't imagine 15,000 people are gonna
sit at a podcast and just be like and
I'm just gonna be like
like a giant thing but I'm dying to know
his his podcast was the number three
music podcast on iTunes
recently so hey look I'm sorry all
things comedy to take listeners away I
know he's not part of all things comedy
but look I might get involved I'm making
a visit was short I might get part of
all short all things short network you
know you guys have been great to me but
I had to move on
and be with my people and when people
that have more in common with contact me
you know I got to make hard choices and
I don't talk to me about this off the
air it's too sensitive this is just I am
we're just I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
ghost this network one day and you'll
know where I am
so anyway everyone comes see that I've
got a lot of LA gigs coming up over the
next few months oh my god wait wait
before we go well obviously my part of
the all things comedy network you can
see it could all things comedy comm go
to facebook.com slash I seem fun
interact with other Facebook and I seem
fun errs at I seem fun podcasts on
Twitter I will be okay everyone get your
tickets December 3rd it's the Jen
Kirkman dysfunctional holiday show at
the Hollywood improv it's 8 o'clock
Saturday December 3rd it's gonna be
[ __ ] fun I throw candy at people we
sing songs I'm gonna have a thing where
I make the audience rate like their
darkest secret about the holiday like I
hate my husband or something I'm gonna
collect them all in a Santa hat and all
the comedians are gonna read them at the
end of the night and we've got Laurie
kill Martin Eddie Pepitone Solomon
Georgie oh it's a [ __ ] great show
Solomon told me he was born on Christmas
Day and his parents forgot his birthday
once so he's got [ __ ] up stories any
Pepitone is gonna be yelling about
everything that he yells about about how
we're all [ __ ] and we're all
distracting ourselves with Frank Sinatra
music and Laurie has a wonderful family
[ __ ] up stories and we're it's all
just a ball of negativity recognizing
that it's a [ __ ] up time of year but
we're having fun despite it's not a
miserable show it's the antidote to all
the fake holiday cheer we're having real
holiday cheer despite the fact that
things are so terrible and that we have
this beautiful
holiday but then you gotta go and spend
it with people you don't always want to
spend it with right so get tickets for
that portion of the proceeds are going
to the LA Regional Food Bank and that is
no joke we even have like W nines I mean
The Improv is getting involved in the
paperwork it's really going to be
donated and then I'm working with this
place called the pajama program and they
provide pajamas and books to kids in
orphanages waiting to be adopted if
that's not Christmassy I don't know what
is if that's not Christmassy so I
encourage you if you come to the show a
part of your ticket price is already
going to charity but be extra charitable
and bring a pair of pajamas for a child
age zero to 18 and a book I would
concentrate probably more on children's
books
don't bring some smutty young adult
novel and all you have to do is drop
them off and I will get them to the
organization so you don't have to do
anything but be a good person and then
sit down have a couple drinks enjoy
yourself
and I think it'll be fantastic it sells
out every year so I really would love it
if you guys could get tickets now it's
Jen Kirkman com click on tour dates and
that should be up there or you can
always go to improv calm and go to
Hollywood and then find the date which
again is Saturday December 23rd it's the
[ __ ] it's my favorite night of the
year the Jen Kirkman dysfunctional
holiday show so I really hope that the I
seem funders will come it's a tonal and
I think I'm gonna show like a clip of a
hallmark movie and dissect it like it's
gonna be different it's not just stand
up there'll be all kinds of stuff going
on I think you get the idea but I can't
seem to stop talking okay well I have
gone one and a half minutes over but I
am in big trouble too short doesn't mind
if I go over here he told me but all
things caught me coming down on me I
already see where the oh it's not on my
website
god dammit don't go to Jen Kirkman
comedy the [ __ ] tickets I didn't put
it up yet just go to just go to hell biz
where you should go go to improv comm
join my email list so go to Jen Kirkman
comm slash about and you'll get them an
email list well this has been fun of the
aliens don't get us but in case they do
until the aliens get us have fun yay